well new at five tonight can your
playlist lead to love
a relatively new dating app is using
music compatibility to make a match
kirsten joyce joining us now in the
studio with the details denise
dating during the pandemic has been a
challenge but that is not why the
founder of the finally
created this app the idea really came
because
i saw my friends and family struggling
on sort of the more traditional dating
apps
where it was just sort of perpetual
swiping and
you know these same people were huge
music fans um like i
am and so i saw this opportunity to
create a dating app that would work for
them
rachel van nortwick launched the vinyly
app in the apple store in october of
2019 just a few months before the
pandemic began
it works like this they take your
spotify listing history combined with a
few questions about music your first
last concerts things like that use an
algorithm
that produces matches for you based off
those answers
the dating app usage has grown
significantly in the past few months and
it's free it's nice for people who
um just want to get in check it out and
then you know as i said
within the app you have choices around
commitment levels so even if you're just
looking for like concert buddies
and right now what that can mean is you
know just somebody who
can watch a live stream with you or talk
about music and sharing that right now
it's on ios but will be launching on
android any day now
finally is partnered with musicians on
call which is an organization that's
been going into hospitals for like 20
years
providing music to those in the hospital
and as we all know right now
they'll be live streaming those concerts
for people in the hospital so as rachel
likes to say her app connects people
with music
and with their partnership heals people
through music as well
and bruce springsteen is one of those
musicians who works a lot with the
organization to give back to those in
the hospital
yeah one of my favorites exactly if
kirsten joyce
was on that app her profile would put
jethro tall and fog hat at the very top
no way you two is on there
you know it's interesting because you
can tell a lot from someone by the last
concert they went to
yes so i i mean i think it really kind
of makes sense for matching too
what was our last concert folks oh geez
mine was you two years ago here what
about you guys
uh bruno mars at park mgm yeah
i think it may have been springsteen
predictable
we just learned a lot in those two
minutes
our